what's a normal mission look like how
are you getting the tasking
what are you are you are you meeting
with guys beforehand are you meeting
with the sealed platoons and going over
hey here's where you want to get dropped
off
well how's that what does that look like
well carl couldn't speak to that because
he had he
was with the seals on death six we
didn't have any seals with us
we just had the swift boats and there
wasn't a lot of coordination with the
swift boats except when they got in
trouble
they called us up and scrambled us for
for close air support when they got into
trouble
but the seals those missions were
coordinated and i'll let carl speak to
that because
they had many types of missions as you
know
jocko they uh and and many times they
would just be advising us look we're
gonna
go in at night and we're gonna go buy a
boat you know with they've got a kit
carson scout that's gonna lead him in
intelligence says xyz is here and they
would let us
you know where they're gonna be and then
coordinates of where they're gonna be
and and uh and i'll tell a story here
about john sandoz
i'll use your name john and an
outstanding officer and the good news on
him is he operated
often in heavy and nightly it seemed
like
i don't think he got it there was one
purple heart in his group but he was a
heavy operator
and hats off to him on that one so but
he did a night operation one night
he'd let us know where he's going to be
in and i was we were on ready five
the scramble aircraft were all our gear
is all in we've done all the checks
we've cranked it once it's ready to go
and you
literally hop in there and you're
airborne and like
you know i've heard term three minutes
we made we got off a lot quicker than
three minutes
lots of times and
we got airborne and it was black
literally black well with pre-brief john
we gave john
uh what the strobe what was the strobe
called that we had john that we
carried the little strobes that it had a
guard around it and it was
oh a directional strobe yeah it was a
good and he had one
and he had a prick 90 radio of mine that
i gave him
because it was small and it was easy to
operate and so
john himself
tough seal he's out there and the enemy
is over here and
freedom's over here and john is between
both of them and he's going to defend
and he's out there uh see wolf one three
uh
uh put some fire in uh northeast about
three
about uh uh zero three zero
and just walk it in and i'll tell you
when to stop
okay so we we i rolled in
and started laying rockets in it
and it was hilarious he goes okay a
little closer uh a little
closer uh and his voice starts racing a
little bit closer
last closer now and i could hear
yeah i could hear rockets going off in
the background
and i was i hear i am safe and sound at
800 feet or whatever i was 600 feet
and it was hilarious and i never let him
forget that
ever so when you're flying at
i mean it's really uh how black it can
be
at night like it can be so dark outside
so when it's that dark you're just
flying pure instruments you're just
looking at yours
you're not even looking out outside
because there's nothing to see
unless you're looking at fire coming up
at you okay that
in some cases then it's real bright
sometimes you get lucky
and there's a moon out and if there's a
moon out then you get flashes of light
off the squigglies and rivers and
streams and yeah
and but yeah there's nights out there
when you're like this and that's when
you have to have a co-pilot who knows
what he's doing
who can navigate because you're busy as
hell keeping that thing on altitude on
heading
and realize you've got a wingman who's
got to have discipline too
he's got to know the heading you're on
and now you've got any collision like
top and bottom so you can keep track of
each other
but it's uh it can get hairy out there
at night and it's
uh you know some guys you look over one
time i mentioned earl shot's name earl
was a cop of mine many times good guy
but he was over there like this he got
the leans pretty bad
because the semi-circular canal is kind
of getting messed up and you think
you're level but you're not when you
start when you start getting vertigo
he's over there like us i said okay or
it was just
we weren't in combat or anything we were
just flying he's over there leaning
sideways i said
okay earl you got he said oh that's okay
no errol you got it
and i'm over there laughing the crew's
laughing but uh
earl excellent pilot but once in a while
you can get them like that but uh
no it is dark and it's like
um how do you say the inside of
somebody's rectum how do you say that
nicely
i think you just did it yeah okay
but but once again if you do it enough
you you know how to do it and
you're comfortable doing it